this truly is dangerously cheesy mac and
cheese inside of a cheeto or mac and
cheese flavored cheese or is it like
Cheetos sprinkled I'm like I don't know
it's a mixture of the two I could love
it I could hate it I could poop
uncontrollably or I could just hum it
hmm the box of cute who thought this
would be a good idea
it smells like honey oh my goodness this
smells like Pringles and cheeses oh my
god it doesn't look like it came from
the earth at all it looks like you came
from Mike Murphy you're drunk you're
probably gonna want this yeah I just
kind of feel like I would order two
boxes of these and then blame it on like
somebody else I call I'm getting this
for my boyfriend and just go home any
both of the boxes this case like box
macaroni and cheese on the inside like
crap yeah you don't really know where
the cheeto ends and the math begins
are you eating a third one no yes I'm
saying good work on amenities my stomach
is already hurting and I've had three
one what would you give these out of ten
I would say maybe like us yeah like a
six I would give it like a five that was
a little drunk
give it a seven it's not as nasty as I
thought it would be um less and you
should never eat them again
finger-licking good
so it's it's half an hour later and we
really don't feel that well I can't tell
us it's coming back up Oh
I was like can't decisions